I know let me bring you in from
Westminster here what do you make of
Labor stance and all this I mean
essentially the government's case is
that this is going to enshrine existing
worker protections well it's for the
Labour Party decide how it responds to
the bill from a trade union perspective
we our main concern is to ensure that
working people's rights are protected
not just simply on day one when we leave
the EU but also into the future the
Prime Minister and the government has
made repeated commitments that they will
protect workers rights but there's
absolutely nothing in this bill that
will ensure that those rights are safe
not just simply on day one but in years
and months to come and these are cool
rights that working people rely on every
day whether it's holiday pay whether
it's protection from discrimination
whether it's assistance for working
parents and indeed whether it's
protection for some of the most
vulnerable and in our society zero hours
contract workers agency workers we want
better protections for these call rights
in the workplace
well David David Davis has been at pains
today to say that ministers are not
going to use these Henry the eighth's
powers to affect things like human
rights law or labour legislation you
you're not satisfied with that you
aren't happy with just taking him on
trust well we hope we can take you on
trust but we'd like him to act on those
promises and to amend the bill to make
clear that none of the wide-ranging
powers within this legislation can be
used to sneak through changes to
employment rights to key rights that
workers rely on we know there are plenty
of lawyers out there plenty of employers
and politicians who are calling for a
bonfire of Rights we say the government
needs to act now to stick by its words
and to deliver its promise for working
people well let's talk to someone who
represents a lot of employers in the
city here Myles what do you make of what
you've heard today so from our
perspective this is the start of a
process that withdrawl bill is the
beginning as Paul's rightly said there
is a long way to go in terms of what the
final future relationship with the EU
looks like the final regulatory
relationship that we have with the
European Union for our industry is going
to be absolutely vital and it's also
vital from the European perspective that
they can continue to have access to
what's the world's leading financial and
related professional services ecosystem
terms of what we're looking for were you
call for a long time for this to be a
fairly clear process where there's no
policy change this is about the
smoothest possible most orderly move as
we move out of the European Union the
time for policy changes is a separate
time future government to this
government future administration's can
look at that in terms of what they
require and what they've been elected
and what mandate they have this is much
more about maintaining that stability
and their ongoing certainty that
businesses need in order to serve
customers and clients the government's
in a very difficult position because its
plan is is quite a rational one it wants
to transplant EU law into UK law so that
on brick's at day plus one we have a
mirror image and that's a basis for
legal certainty for people and for
companies and to do that it does need
the power to amend that legislation to
make sure that it works and it needs the
power to amend it to make sure that it
complies with whatever whatever is being
negotiated and I think actually the
government's been quite clear that the
amendments are only rectifications
they're not seeking to change employment
rights which are guaranteed by EU law
until in a later stage this is all about
freeze framing EU law as a basis of
cooperation for thee but with the EU